ce sont des chiffres encourageants pour
Marina Silva la ministre de
l'Environnement et ses fonctionnaires
nous avons obtenu une baisse cumulée de
33,6 % l'effort d'inversion de la courbe
fonctionne c'est un fait la
déforestation n'est pas en hausse sous
bolsonaro elle avait augmenté de 75% en
4 ans dès son élection Lula a promis de
mettre fin à la déforestation illégale
d'ici 2030 mais si elle n'est pas en
hausse elle n'a pas encore cessé pour
autant l'objectif ne sera pas facile à
atteindre
le mois dernier le président Lula a
annoncé la saisie immédiate des zones
exploitées illégalement dans les espaces
protégés les a augmenté considérablement
et il a renforcé les pouvoirs et les
effectifs de l'IBA l'Institut brésilien
de l'environnement et des ressources
naturelles renouvelables les défis sont
gigantesques
de bois et exploitation illégale de la
forêt pêche illégale et aussi crime
organisé un défi complexe et difficile à
affronter dynaministre
la preuve en janvier dernier l'armée
brésilienne a dû intervenir dans la
réserve des indigènes à nos mamies
envahi par les Gary peyros les
chercheurs d'origo et bien ce n'est pas
fini des présidents de l'IBAMA
Perros travaillent la nuit pour ne pas
se faire prendre on dirait une opération
de guerre et il n'y a pas que le Brésil
la province amazonienne de Napo en
Équateur est envahi par les mineurs
illégaux comme au Brésil il détruisent
l'environnement répandent des matières
polluantes et font fuir les touristes
dans la vallée de Javary où se
rencontrent trois pays amazoniens le
Brésil la Colombie et le Pérou les
indigènes sont assiégés par les pêcheurs
illégaux les braconniers les exploitants
forestiers et les trafiquants de drogue
l'Union des autochtones du Javary a
décidé de prendre les choses en main il
patrouille le Javary constamment ils se
font appeler les guerriers de la forêt
tous les gouvernements de la région qui
connaissent des difficultés économiques
sont totalement débordées et il
subissent les pressions de tous les pays
du monde inquiets de la survie de
l'Amazonie Jean-Michel le prince du
Canada Montréal